so hello everybody
i hope you are having a wonderful
beginning of the year
i shouldn't laugh i'm laughing because
things are
nuts and we all knew that they would be
nuts but it's unpleasant to go through
the nuts
stuff anyways even though we all knew
that it was going to be crazy
so it's good to see some of the people
in the chat
it's good to see griswold grim i think i
recognize you from
the the
what is it the the the with the name of
the channel man my
my brain is gonna be horrible tonight
it's not gonna be good
um and uh so brad's there
neil is there jacob
nice sorting yourself out that channel
oh my goodness
sorry about that all right and so all
right so let's do this let's go
uh i wanted to make a few announcements
as you see i'm slowly starting to
inhabit this space i'm still not totally
ready yet but it's
it's getting there it's getting there
i'm starting to have stuff that i'm
gonna put up
some stuff that i saw like my adam and
eve thing i stole from the flood i got
it out of the water
uh and it still looks okay there's a bit
of rust on it i might have to
take care of but it looks okay and i put
my brother's book
up there and so i'm gonna have some
books in there in the uh
so i'm just setting up i'm happy um
so this year is going to be the year
that i'm going to redo the website
um one of the reasons to redo the
website is
to make it more streamlined make it more
easily accessible especially the blog
posts that are being done
you know that it's not super streamlined
i want people to be able to get to the
content easily and that it the content
be featured
another another purpose to redoing the
website
is that you know um i made this big
thing on facebook on the facebook group
saying that you know
it's facebook and twitter are becoming
dangerous faces to to rely on and so
i thought okay let's move jacob the
who you've seen on my channel before uh
he's jake of the fool in the chat
he he had had a discord channel that was
talking about symbolism so we thought
we'd move there and so we did a lot of
people did move to discord but discord's
different the way that it works
there isn't like the post and and
comment
uh functionality it's more like a stream
conversation so it's not for everybody
anyways so one of the things i'm going
to be doing and i'm kind of announcing
this to all the moderators here as well
is i'm going to be having uh forums on
the website
and so that way and the website is being
hosted by
um someone named matthew ramer and a
company called content safe
uh and so they're very deliberate about
making sure that the content
will at least be protected to some
extent if uh if things start to go
off the rails if there starts to be
attacks and so if we have forums on the
website
that way we can um
that way we can at least control more
and we can decide the functionalities we
want it's all have some discussions with
lisa and elise is there by the way
it's like in it's like at three o'clock
in the morning therefore i think it's
like
worse than that anyways so lisa and brad
and jacob and all the moderators and uh
decide how what kind of functionalities
they want for the group i think it would
be better to have that on the website
so that's like a big change that's going
to be happening soon i'm working with a
marketing company now to kind of set
that up
and to centralize everything so in the
move what we want to do to protect
ourselves
is we want to focus on the website
because we have control over
over the information over the people we
know like we can know who's there and we
can contact them if
if things start to get weird and so what
i want to encourage people to do
is to is to sign up on the website if
you go to the website
at the bottom of the page there's like a
there's like a subscribe to
the symbolic world and uh the idea is if
you're subscribed
then you know you'll be you'll be
connected through the website so if
youtube decides to do whatever and we
have to go
through bit shoot or through another
video service then at least you'll get
notifications through email
uh for the video so i'm encouraging
people to do that you know so
that we we're ahead of the curve if
things start to go weird
on us uh and so to encourage that i
i'm gonna do something
all right so so to encourage people to
sign up for the website i'm being like a
real youtuber
now you'll notice watch this out all
right check this out so i have
i'm going to uh raffle off two things
i'm gonna raffle off
a uh a uh image of everything sweater
this dark sweater
which is what is it what size it so it's
a large medium sweater
and i'm also going to raffle off a a
tote bag with
our patron saint michael uh so that he
can protect
your stuff and so so
next month at the beginning at the q a
i before the q a i will raffle off
uh one one thing for everybody who
subscribed to the website
and one thing for everybody who's
supporting me as a patron
on the website or through patreon or
whatever and so if you're
so in a way if you're already supporting
me on patreon it's like two you get two
chances to win this so
this is just a kind of i know it's i
know because i hate going on websites
and signing up
so i want to like really entice you to
go and do that
so that you know in a few months when
things start getting
really loopy uh we will
be able to continue to have discussions
on symbolism and to kind of hold the
line
at least for a while um until until it
gets so bad that then we can't but
you know we'll we'll we'll we want to be
ahead of the curve
all right so that's so that's uh all
right here we go
so as you know uh the way it works is
that people that are supporting me at 10
or more get to ask questions in advance
and uh
and then then i'll go to super chats at
the end
usually it usually that's about as much
as i can do like it's hard for me to get
into the to the q
a because it's just it's already it
already lasts like almost two hours when
we do it this way
so you know one day i'm thinking so
maybe sometimes i'll maybe have like two
two streaming so that people that are in
the chat can have a chance to ask
questions sometimes
so but anyways for now at least that's
the best way that i found
of doing this and just remind you if
people write too long
a question like a really really long
comment i probably will skip your
question
just because it's difficult to like read
long text and then answer them
right
all right and so m-f-p-r-i-s-l
michael sorry from michael it says did
theology
ruin everything did we focus too much in
the west on juggling statements about
faith like they were abstract formula
and loss
and thus lost their meaning after a
religious high school i was able to
catalogue heresies based on
my new details like 19th century
biologist catalog species
but i did not really get the meaning of
the teaching before i listen to lord of
spirits podcast
all they say is in line with what i was
taught but they make the abstract
theology incarnate
so i think that it's not so much it's
not so much the idea that
you need to think that um that it's
useless or that it's not important i
think it's mostly that
you need to balance things have to be
balanced so it's okay to be interested
in theology and even to be interested in
varying my new theology some of the
great
some of the great people that i that i
love like sam max was the confessor was
was involved very very minutely and some
very
uh you know how can i say this like
really really tight questions about
theology
i'm not that kind of person i'm not that
interested in that so but i think it's
fine to do that
you just have to balance it out and know
that theology is not going to save you
it's like having the right theology is
not going to save your soul
and that it has to be embodied you know
that your faith has to be embodied your
your christian life has to be embodied
um and of course
your theology will will help you to kind
of orient yourself but
it has to be more than that um and i do
think that that
these these theological uh minutia
has a meaning like it has a metaphysical
meaning and an ontological meaning and
and those
actually kind of manifest themselves in
the world but i
agree with you that a lot of times
people don't seem to
to care or know or understand the
relationship and so because of that
it looks just arbitrary and i've no i
think i told you guys before there are a
few things where i don't totally
understand them i
i can see that the fathers were fighting
for this or that detail
but i i cannot i i'm fine with it i'm
not gonna go against it but i also don't
totally
see how it lands in the world you know
sometimes i do sometimes i don't
so kingsley asks any symbolic insight on
the trisagian
prayers
it's interesting it's interesting that
you asked that because i've been
thinking about that
i've been thinking about that a lot you
know
i've been thinking about trying to
understand the version
of the trusagian prayer in the orthodox
church like what is the symbolic
pattern that's there and i have to admit
with you that i don't
totally feel like i have it i can give
you a general statement so those who
don't know
the true sagion prayer is that it's
usually holy god
holy mighty holy and immortal have mercy
on us so it's like holy god holy mighty
holy and immoral have mercy on us so
it's like three invocations of god
uh you know three three kind of titles
of god or three invocations of god's
different aspects
and it definitely has to do with that
with
the idea like a general notion it has to
do with the idea that
we are joined with the angels because
that holy holy holy
comes from the from scripture the the
the
this idea of the the uh the angels
that's the this was it the seraphim
cherubim seraphim did sing holy holy
holy lord
lord saba like lord of the ancient of
days um
and so that you can see that it's
related to that and there are several
pla several prayers
in script in the liturgy that we join
kind of these old testament prayers of
glory with like new testament
prayers and so the idea would be that
now the holy holy holy
is trinitarian like he becomes
trinitarian when in
the old testament or for jews for
example they wouldn't necessarily
understand it as trinitarian
um so that would be the but i i
struggled to see even in the holy god
holy mighty
holy and immortal like is it a
trinitarian thing i'm not sure like i'm
not sure that it relates to the
three persons of the trinity and if it
does i don't totally
i don't totally see it clearly so i'm
sorry about that
that i can't answer you in a better way
on that question
i always try to be honest if i feel like
i don't know something and i don't know
it
um all right so
hi jonathan can you talk a bit about
maximus's writing about god's movement
in the unity
monad to rest in the tried multiplicity
talks about the movement towards
perfection and fulfillment
but i'm having trouble grasping it yeah
well that's one of those things where
i'm going to have trouble grasping it as
well or
not grasping it but grasping what
exactly
is the relationship like i can tell you
my
my let's say
vision like if when you say it the way
you said it for example the idea of
moving from perfection to
fulfillment it's it's the question it's
this whole question about the trinity
is that you know there's a tendency to
see the one
as being higher than the many as the
oneness of god is being higher than the
trinity
but there's also a way that you can
understand it almost like the
like the opposite where the three
persons
are like the fullness of divinity they
like
they they they fill out or
you know are like the glory of the of
the
the glory of the the essence you know
and so
that's kind of the weird mystery in
christianity is this importance on
hypostasis or this important on
the person as not just an embodiment of
like
of a higher idea but an actual
like like or yeah like a fulfillment of
what that ideal is so it's actually some
the revelation of something is somehow
in some ways fuller than the principle
that it has more uh and that's like a
it's a strange thing it's hard to
totally understand it but
you see it for example in the whole
story of scripture
where this sense that the new jerusalem
or the heavenly jerusalem
is more than the garden and it's more in
adding like it has the fullness of the
city
added to the the primacy of the garden
let's say
and so that's as close as i'm going to
get to understanding that
but i might be wrong
all right so josh the mover asked the
mother of god in some saints have
allegedly
been appearing to to people lately
telling them not to wear
masks in church for state ordinance my
own church requires them
and i haven't been able to properly
venerate an icon since i
started attending in june the consensus
at first was to be patient and wait for
the ordinance to pass
but it's beginning to look like that
demon never come indeed
i'm a catechumen and i don't want to
overstep my boundaries but at what point
is it the church's duty to civilly
disobey the state
it's never permissible for a lady to
make demands of this sort
to clergy so this is what i
suggest to you is
that you need to obey your authority
like you need to obey what your
authority
tells you to do and the response of the
spiritual responsibility of what's going
on will fall on them that is if they are
making the wrong decision
and if i don't know about this
appearances of of
of saints and and the virgin like i i
don't know i don't want to
i'd have no desire to uh to
pass judgment on that but it's uh it's
the authorities that need to be able to
take the take the right decision so if
they're taking the wrong decision and
you might think so and i might think so
um we still need to obey the
decision that doesn't mean that we need
to be
it doesn't mean that we can't find ways
to
make petitions or we can't find ways to
express or to help or to ask
and to wonder about the reasons for
certain things
and so it is completely acceptable for
the parish
to question the authority
that's one of the reasons for that's one
it's one of the the natural aspects of
what it means to be under someone is to
question
but then ultimately even if you question
you need to obey the the authority
because if you don't then what are you
gonna do what are you gonna show up in
church without a mask and
and then what like you know and then the
priest doesn't want to give you
communion and then you you're in a fight
with your priest and it's like
the priest gives you communion you can't
take communion so
i don't know like what it would do to uh
yeah to do that but you know there are
ways to prod and poke and see
you know how solid people feel this this
um
this restriction is in wherever it is
you're living like we don't need we
don't even have church services now
we are our churches are closed right now
so
um so david flores
asks is unrestrained self-indulgence a
symbolic element of the zombie i feel
like the rotten flesh has a connection
to excess
yes circumcision indeed as well
insatiable hunger yeah so it does have
to do
with the idea of uh this
excess of eating and this this this
slave to desire
so the idea of the zombie is a is a
slave to one desire he's such a slave to
that desire that that's all
that animates the zombie there's nothing
left in the in the zombie
except for that hunger right the hunger
for flesh
and so the the and the flesh
is this kind of raw outer flesh like you
said and so
it is the falling into the passion of
of desire for flesh where you understand
it in terms of eating or in terms of
sexuality
uh it does have to do with the amps
the lack of restraint or the lack of a
see
aesthesis which is what circumcision
ultimately also represents for the
christian this idea of
the circumcision of the heart this
removal of the outer
influences the removal of the of the the
weight of the flesh and so
it's like there's nothing wrong once
again with the body but it's rather
it's rather being a slave to this
outside sometimes you have to remove the
garments
remove the garments of skin
so roxanne asks what do you think of the
fairy tale found in the grimm brothers
collection iron john
in 1990 the poet robert bleix founded it
as a guidance for masculinity he hosted
men's gatherings to defend masculinity
from a perceived threat in those days
a folk version is wiley and the hairy
man i'm afraid i do not know
i do not know this um this fairy tale so
i'm sorry about that
it would be difficult for me to answer
that iron john well definitely look into
it though
it's very interesting iron john
okay so i see there's there's actually
like a book about it
um iron skin man
all right i have to look into this all
right i have to get to this if it's
interesting i'll make a video about it
or something
i keep saying that and then i don't make
videos about things
all right man i'm in a weird mood
tonight i hope i don't say anything
stupid
okay so jacob jakub asks a question
about the eucharist
catholics and protestants are in the
endless tug of war between real presence
and just a symbol
sorry
all right real presence are just a
symbol would it be fair to say that
jp's an orthodox stance would be
that would be a symbol without the just
and thus real yes exactly i've said this
before if
i've said it in several videos where i
once heard a deacon who actually then
became a priest later
who said that protestants believe that
the eucharist is is symbolic
the catholics believe that the eucharist
is real and we orthodox we believe that
it is real because it is symbolic and i
thought it was such a great way
of of talking about that it's one of
those moments where you feel like okay
i'm at home in the orthodox church like
this is where i belong uh and so yes
that's it is that because we don't
believe that the world is arbitrary and
because we believe that
the world lays itself out you know
through the divine energies of god which
underlay all of manifestation
therefore the world appears as full of
meaning full of pattern full of light
and so it is symbolic and therefore
the the the the present the symbolism of
the entire
liturgy is is is also the reality of it
you know so yes so pnumaish asks
what are the judges in the book of
judges judging
to me they don't seem to be functioning
the same as the judges that moses set up
it looks like they're not acting in some
position of judicial court but rather
they are judging the nations that were
present israel at the time yes
uh that's because for some i don't know
why they call them judges they're not
judges
and i don't know why we call it the book
of judges they're they're prophets
it's like they're just prophets and so
the book of judges could be called the
book of prophets or something like that
and so they they
they act as prophets but they're they're
they're different from the prophets that
you find later
you know like isaiah or daniel or
ezekiel
they're they're prophets in the sense
that they're kind of charismatic
leaders that inspired by god you know
become momentary
uh like momentary inspirations for the
people of israel
through the will of god and so that's
what they're doing
you know and so maybe that's why they
call them judges is because they want to
separate them from just the prophet that
has visions and then tells people about
them
these are more like you know the spirit
of god comes in them and then they drive
a stake through someone's head you know
like the story of jail and all these
other wild stories
and judges but the important thing about
understanding judges
is that there's a there are a lot of
there's a different narrative that's
going on in the book of judges
and one of the narratives is that this
is the effect of not having a king yet
so it often says there was not yet a
king in israel
and when it described some horrific
thing that happened or some really
disturbing element um
and so despite the fact that you find in
samuel
this this um this warning about
having a king and how and how in a way
there are dangers to having a king
there's also another
discourse which is happening at the same
time in the book of judges which is that
without a king things are wild like
things are
it's difficult to have coherence without
this
this permanent figure of authority above
you um
and so that's one of the things that's
other stuff that's going on in
judges all right and so
white year two asks do you see any
symbolism in bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies
cannot help but see cryptocurrency as a
another iteration of the destruction of
hierarchy
season inscription has been replaced
with collective self-interest indeed and
with cryptocurrency
trade can theoretically happen
independent of any specific authority
right now the system works but i wonder
if it is sustainable and whether there
might be some snakes in the bitcoin
garden
um do you see a cryptocurrency as a
fundamental breakdown in reality or is
trades something that can work in a
peer-to-peer way without any authority
and so i do think that it is definitely
a continuation of
a breakdown there's no doubt about that
and it is a it is also a desire to
to remove authority from from the system
of exchange
um and so what it does is it
it opens up a it opens up a
space for freedom and so this is the
thing it's like you can
you can see what it does like this is
this really actually could probably
really help you to understand
uh what what
what this what happens with this kind of
stuff and so
you can understand that like let's say
the closer something is to
a kind of stability right or a kind of
anchoredness
then the more stable it is
but it also the less
possibilities you have okay let's say it
that way
and so the closer you are so so imagine
that you have a system monetary system
which is completely dependent which
actually let's say you don't even have a
monetary system
you just have gold coins or silver coins
you have coins
in which the the value of the metal is
the actual money
that is being produced in the land and
so it's like you have a piece of silver
yeah it might have the
the stamp of the king on it to say to
encourage people to think that it's real
silver
but what matters is that it's a piece of
silver and it's like it's it's almost
like bartering right so it's like it has
a value
and it's directly exchanged and so that
is extremely stable but it also
lacks potentiality lacks possibility and
so if you create a monetary system
which is based on promise and it's and
which is based on
on uh you know the promise of paying
then it becomes less stable
but it also increases possibility and
what we've seen
is that as we move towards the modern
time the
the governments have tried to
add more possibility as much as possible
and so and so in order to do that
they've they've broken it apart
from an actual value more and more just
kept
breaking it kept breaking it apart and
so to a point where
you know now the difference between a
fiat currency base that's produced in
canada
and a fiat currency which is bitcoin
it's like the only thing that's holding
it together is basically the authority
of the state
so there is something and and it would
still be more stable than bitcoin
but that's why bitcoin is like this
right bitcoin is like you know
what is it in 2011 it was like when no
when was it like at some point it was
like two it was like 11
or something for a bitcoin or 50 or
something and now it's like
i don't even know where it is now
whether 50 000 or whatever and so
that's the that's what that's what these
type of
of uh unanchored systems
of value uh will do you know and you can
see it's similar to what's happening in
the stock market it's like
the stock market has very little to do
with the actual value of the companies
look at the whole gamestop thing but
it's not just gamestop that's just one
glaring example that happened
recently but you can see that even
during covet and after kovi people were
surprised
to see the stock market continued to
rise because
it has been detached from actual
reality like actual value and so what it
does is it will
offer way more possibility but it can
also
offer way more risk and then it can also
crash
so we all know that and if you want to
know i
i myself am not interested in that stuff
in terms of
personal things and i like i'm happy for
people that are and i
and i'm excited when people tell me that
they just made you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars
of bitcoin or off of of of the shortstop
thing that they're doing and i'm like
that's awesome for you but i
really for me at least i don't it's not
something that i'm interested in
and if i do invest it's going to be in
uh in things that are palpable and
things that are
that have some connection to who i am
and what i do
what i care about um so
and i don't care enough about money to
just
be in money it's like i'd want to create
something you know
anyway so that's that's me but
all right so luca skovic asks once we
put something into a certain frame that
will come true in one form or another
for good or bad how do we stop this
process
these cycles or should we even stop them
if i got it right hindus call them
karmic knots
here are some examples almost anyone
that was certain that covet doesn't
exist
got the coveted with really bad symptoms
whenever i made fun of someone it always
came back to bite me
sometimes seconds sometimes years later
so in the sense of like
the whole idea of karma um
i understand what you're saying like
this idea of
if you attend to something you know uh
then you you you oh you put it on
the on your horizon of possibilities
and so you know like you said if you
if you do something bad to someone else
you are putting that as a possibility
you're opening up that possibility in
your
world and so it's not a it's not a
one-for-one thing like i don't believe
that there's like a
just like a like a really kind of really
tight system but uh
there's there's definitely a loose
system of of opposition
and of opposites and so if you if you're
not careful and you open up spaces for
bad things by doing bad things then
you're in that world
you're you're you're going to be in that
that space and so it's going to
it's going to come back to uh
get you um
so nicos says would it be acceptable as
a christian to assassinate hitler in
world war
ii um you mean
in like it depends i mean if you were if
you were an english soldier and you were
acting under order it would certainly be
acceptable
to assassinate hitler in world war ii of
course
you might have to go to confession
afterwards but it still would happen
that's a weird thing about orthodox uh
orthodox uh soldiers is that although
although they
they um they're allowed to go to war and
to kill people
they still need to to go to confession
and to kind of
amend for their sins so um so someone
says that bitcoin is 33 000 usd so yes
when i said 50
000 i was living in uh
i was more like canadian money so that's
probably similar that's probably
something like that no it's more like 40
something thousand
canadian um so
timothy asks law sorry
timothy i never know how to say your
name right
so hey jonathan the more i re i learn
about renaissance art the weirder it
appears to me drawing god the father
painting saint peter at the left hand of
christ instead of his right cherubs as
babies saints are drawn in the nude in a
weird muscular body
i'm struggling to understand how the
catholic church ever commissioned and
improved these works of art
what was going on and so i agree with
you obviously
if you watch my discussion with uh with
father john strickland you'll see
that i obviously this is definitely
agree
that i think i think what happened in
the renaissance
is a kind of neo-paganism
and uh and but it's interesting because
it tapered off
afterwards and so like the great artist
whatever in parenthesis these like great
artists like
like michelangelo and and rubens and all
these really excessive artists
you know they were famous and we talked
about them in they're all these big
churches but
that kind of stuff would never have gone
into like the normal churches
and so a village church would never have
had
something that would like that it would
have been way more sober
way more toned down even if baroque it
would have not been you wouldn't have
like
naked women you know cavorting around or
whatever
um it would have been way more sober and
so i think that
that's an important thing to understand
in terms of the excesses of the elites
that happened during the renaissance and
the post renaissance period
and uh village church which would have
been probably way more conservative
um but it's it's it's
it's really is to me a pagan moment in
in christianity the renaissance
and and it's a decadence there's a
decadence
in the in the art that i talk i didn't
talk about father john strickland but is
there's a decadence in the meaning and
so in the middle ages there had
developed this amazingly powerful
relationship kind of cosmic language of
symbolism and so
in the renaissance and after the
renaissance
the symbolism became more and more
kind of hermetic and closed off and
and uh and not and a little arbitrary
rather than you know based in scripture
and liturgy and so
in an icon you can you can understand
what's going on
because it's bathed in the world of
of scripture and liturgy but if you look
at
you know you know it's like if you look
at
uh the image of the creation of adam
right and so
look it's a great it's a great example
so look at the image of the creation of
adam by
michelangelo and you're like what's
going on
i mean that's not the way even if you
you first of all accept that they drew
god the father which
already is a problem but let's say you
say okay fine it's it's
that's we'll look over that for now it's
like why are they touching fingers
what the heck is that what does that
even mean like what is that
in scripture it says that he blew air
into his nostrils
that's how he created and he spoke the
world into being and he blew air
into into adam and so what is this
what is this and so if if so
it's that's the one of the problems of
renaissance art is that there's a
decadence in the
in not just in the way that it's
represented but there's a decadence in
the iconography where all of a sudden
it's like
these things have become arbitrary and
just like the fancy of the artist
that is not this deep deep uh
plunging into the story and kind of
engagement into the story
um so anyways so yeah you got me ranting
about the renaissance again
it's too easy for me to do that
all right and so all right so
um all right so benjamin rba this is
your benjamin your your question is a
little too long
but all right because it's important i
will i will do it but okay so i
apologize
i continue to struggle with the nature
metaphysical status of higher level
beings
when i hear you describe the angel of
london or france i hear what sounds like
an emergent phenomena
although i also believe that phenomena
phenomenon has its own
kind of agency and consciousness feeding
back to the material world
what i can't shake is the sense that
this angel is contingent
on the earthly that if a nuke were to
wipe out that city and all trace and
memory of it the angel would cease to
exist
and is therefore dependent on the earth
for its being and if this were true
i don't know how the same contingency
would appear applied to the logos of god
logos and god if earth and human
consciousness got blinked out of
physical existence somehow
and that is really not this is not
helpful like that's not helpful
there's nothing in the christianity i've
come to know through you and father
and people like father andrew and
stephen on the lord of spirits
that i'm not all in on
when viewed from the emergent side of
the coin but i sense that to be a real
christian i have to believe
the imminent perspective of and its
primacy
is this where the logo and logos
transcend manifestation please help so
so a way to understand for example like
a way to understand
the idea that the the
a way to understand the idea that the
angel
of london the angel of london doesn't
exist in time the way that we exist in
time and so
it's it's not it you can't really comp
you can't really understand the relation
and i think even father stephen talks
about this in in his podcast
so you you have to understand things
almost in a non-linear manner to
understand the ontological hierarchy of
beings and so
the the the city the angel of a city
you know it exists in eternity in the
mind of god it's not just
something you know in the fullness of
everything
it exists and and and that city exists
and the angel of that city exists as
well and so
it's it's the problem is is that we're
obviously we
can't it's difficult but it's difficult
to move from
this kind of linear time in which we see
things come up and then go away and then
we see things
are being born and and dying uh
and and the totality of everything in
which
all things exist in the kind of
simultaneity of the resurrection
let's say uh and in the simultaneity of
this kind of
this this moment eschatological moment
where all things are revealed
together and this is a reflection of
something like
the existence of all things in the mind
of god from all eternity and so
i'm not helpful when i use those i use
more technical terms like this so i'm i
feel like i'm answering your question
but i'm not helping you because i'm
using
and using techno like uh philosophical
speech but it's the most important thing
to understand
is that
for the angel okay think about it this
way for the angel of new york to
for the city of new york to exist
it has to be moving towards something
it's a the identity of
of something has to proceed to a certain
extent
the manifestation for you to be able to
recognize it right
that's why that's the whole idea in
plato that that
that cogniza cognising or that's not a
word
that to cognate something to to think
something or to recognize something
is to remember something it's like you
that's that's the
thing that plato had the intuition about
that's one of the
things that leads to the notion that
of reincarnation even is this idea that
things have to somehow there's a certain
type of pre-existence
that has to be there there for something
to be recognized
um and so it's that's
what's calling you towards the logos
it's like
it has for you to recognize something it
has to pre-exist
i don't know how it else to say it man
this is tough
this is not helpful i feel like i'm not
being helpful so sorry benjamin
okay so alex asked any thoughts on the
symbolism of the game stop situation
all these ready redditors more or less
spontaneously organized to take
revenge on hedge funds by weaponizing
the stock of a few dying companies
gamestop amc nokia this stuff is tough
because it's kind of like uh
there's something anarch there's an
anarchist
tendency about it there's a i i kind of
sympathize obviously with this
because the elites don't care about us
and so
i sympathize with it but i also think
that it's a very destructive move it's
going it's going to increase
the breakdown but maybe at this point
it's inevitable
because because the elites are only
financial elites and because the elites
don't you know in the normal world the
elites of a country
or a people had responsibility and so
you know that's why
if you look at even even in roman times
the senators or the elites that made a
lot of money from the conquest
they felt responsibility to then build
buildings like to make
public buildings and to do to have all
these gestures
towards the citizens of the city but
in our world the the elites don't care
about anything like they don't care
about you
they they just want to make more money
and so
because of that it's inevitable that
things like gamestop will happen
um but it's definitely it's definitely
breaking things down
faster and you know whatever maybe
that's what we need who knows
like i'm not an accelerationist but i
also
at some point this whole crazy system is
gonna break down
it can't it can't last forever
all right so bogdan asked what is what's
the symbolism of the israelites entering
egypt
as high status honored guests but over
time becoming class
second class citizens and slaves
i've been reading genesis and exodus in
this contrast struck me but i'm not sure
what to make of it
so the solution to that question is
joseph
that's the solution to the quest to that
question the idea
is that the reason why
the reason why egypt saves
the jews is because of joseph
and so this is a lesson
for today by the way uh
when the pharaoh forgot joseph
and then it says something exact i think
it says exactly like that
like the the fair no longer remembered
joseph
and then when the pharaoh no longer
remembered
joseph then the israelites became slaves
in egypt
so there's the image of the of the just
the image of this holy
person who is like the anchor of
the israelites and he
he is able to go out into egypt he's an
image of christ really
he's able to go out into egypt now think
of it for us
go out into rome and
save egypt save rome
and as long as the
pharaoh remembers joseph
then the the place where he came from is
safe
but then when that doesn't happen
anymore then
then they become slaves so
so that's what it has to do and in terms
of your in terms of
of a practical application you can
understand it as
you know if you understand
if you if you have the reason
why you why you act if you have the
thing towards which it
comes together then you can move out
into the world
and the world is not dangerous to you
right so if you if you remember your
purpose
then you won't fall into all these
temptations
right if you know if you act with with
with purpose and focus and memory of god
then you won't fall into temptation but
if you
forget like you in this story it's like
the pharaoh forgets
uh joseph but that in that in this
situation you can see
there's a lot of stories either way if
you
if you describe it either way it's the
same so it's like if you
if if you forget there's forgetting
between those then
you're going to stray and you're going
to become a slave to egypt so if you
forget your purpose
forget your focus your attention then
you're going to get tempted by the
second piece of cake that i always talk
about or
whatever it is that is your passion is
going to take over
and uh yeah
um
all right so all right where are we here
so television smith television smith
asks were you every client experiment
with animation
can an icon move i have experimented
with animation in fact
long ago i have many lives that you guys
don't know about
long ago uh before i went to africa
i worked for a project management
company
and i was developing uh pedagogical
material for them
and in and it was a lot of graphic
design but it also it was the time
during flash animations
well you probably were probably too
young for that so i was doing
i was illustrating course concepts using
flash animations
so like all these little animations of
uh of little stories to kind of
to add to the thing so yes i am
interested in animation i find it very
fascinating
and i would love to see
some animations that would not be icons
it's
i would be careful with that but i would
say to take
some of the iconography for example and
create visual moving visual
representations of
the iconographic programs and so i think
that that could be
awesome and uh and there are some
interesting people that are thinking
about this and
and hopefully and some of them are in
the chat right now
actually or at least one of them right
uh
hopefully one day you know you'll see
that
maybe not an animation or something that
will kind of take
uh take really iconographic thinking
and bring it into a more movement or
visual medium so
hopefully that works that'd be fun um
there's a lot of stuff on there there's
a lot of plans a lot of plans we just
hope that we can get to them you know
because
the last two years have been have been
really slowed me down but i feel like
this
this year you know covet though but you
know this year i feel like things are
gonna
things are going to move it's gonna be
fun
so tan moose man asks the youth congress
said a prayer to a number of deities
four days before storming
of the capital including brahma and then
included with amen and a woman yes
we all heard that very embarrassing a
very embarrassing thing the only
associations i have with brahma are the
hindu deity and the brahma bull
is the fact that a guy with a bull horns
looking like some pagan shaman tattooed
with the hammer thor correlated to the
prayer to brahma
uh seems to me like brahma might have
answered their prayer through a sort of
demonic manifestation
what do you think is this the case of
symbolism happens well it's definitely a
case of symbolism happens
you know it's just another it's just all
of it is just
breakdown guys i mean it's all breaking
down it's all falling apart
and so the fact that someone who has a
theology degree
could say something as hilarious as a
man and a woman
dude that's a that's a scene from a
movie i mean that is hilarious
there's nothing as funny as that and
then
the capital it's i'm sorry i shouldn't
laugh when they call an insurgency but
my goodness
if you watch the video of those guys in
the
in the senate uh room man it was
funny like it was frightening but it was
like a frightening and funny because
these guys were idiots like they were
just these morons
and the kyu shaman is obviously
he's not whatever like he's obviously
confused he's a confused
weird psychedelic you know
multi-dimensional
guy i mean the things he says are just
completely nuts um
it was still fascinating to watch how
they acted and so
i i shared it on social media rachel
fulton brown
wrote an article on that moment
where here are these guys that come in
and they're telling us their
insurrection is
uh but they come in to the senate room
and they're all like
hush like they they're overwhelmed
by this place and they're dressed like
the guy is dressed like an idiot shaman
with like
bull horns like this made up whatever
shaman
nordic half weird christian mixture
and and then in the senate room
there's a guy who's shot in the face
with like a bullet
and a plastic bullet and he says to the
cop he says i'm here to make sure nobody
damages anything and i'm like
what what's going on and then and then
they like go up and they're like
hesitating like oh man you can't go like
you can't go in that chair right
then they they end up doing it like so
the shaman goes up to the
to the to the vice president's chair
and it's like totally overwhelmed so
he's kind of being cocky at the same
time but he's overwhelmed and then they
end up saying a prayer
so he says this like prayer and he ends
the prayer which surprised me
completely with in the name of jesus
right he
i forget exactly how he phrased but he
ended the prayer in the name of jesus
i didn't see that coming at all um
and everybody is all excited so it was
but it's all a sign of
of of this breakdown all of it you know
um and and it's it's also a sign of the
breakdown that you don't know
what's real like we don't know
in the chaos like you don't know who's
who
so that's something like for example
even during the blm riots and the antifa
riots
you know the idea that they are are
whatever back block
an aspect of back block which is
actually police or military that are
dressed as
as uh protesters in order to
provoke reaction like to to bring the
the protest far enough so that the
police will react that's something that
happens like
that's something that really happens
i've seen in montreal there were police
who were breaking windows
and they got filmed they're breaking
windows during student protests
in order to blame it on the protesters
and so
same thing with this this this capital
thing like did the police let them in
how did they get in none of them were
armed so why did they let them in
who knows who knows like that's one of
the aspects of the breakdown and so
everybody says
psyop this psy up that this is fake this
is real
who knows you don't know and people who
think they know they they they don't
know
like when someone tells you it's
definitely a psyops like you don't know
that
or if someone says it's definitely real
you don't know that either because
we're in a situation where it's like a
hall of mirrors
in a carnival and it's all insane
and we don't know who's behind things
and we don't know
we don't know what's real anymore
and that's it like that's the breakdown
guys it's
it's gonna take a while to know what's
real
um and it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna
be so strange that
we are gonna forget what it means to
just know what's real
and that's the situation we're in and
it's gonna be like this for a while
and uh yeah so sorry guys
all right okay so all right finish with
the symbolic world i'm going to go
to subscribe star but i think that there
aren't any questions on subscribe star
today
for some reason
all right no question i'll subscribe
star i think it's also because i posted
this q a
very late in the month and that we are
still when we're actually not in january
but we're
in the first of february so sorry about
that
it's been wild this past month has been
crazy
for everybody i imagine but
all right so here we go so now i'm going
to patreon
so hello nick scott are we truly in the
age of aquarius
thanks all the best i never knew what
that meant i don't know what that means
i know i don't know i don't i don't know
what that means like i don't know what
what what it would mean to be the age of
aquarius
and uh you know ever since what is it
that
that that uh musical hair where they
talk about the age of aquarius like
i don't know i don't know what that
would mean really
sorry i don't know enough about
astrology either
i've always want to know more about
astrology but it's just it's kind of
i just feel like every time i read this
is the thing about astrology
is that i think that ancient astrology
probably had very deep insight into
patterns of reality but i think that
most people today that talk about
astrology
they don't know what they're talking
about and they're just making it up and
so
that's the problem with astrology is
that when you read things people talk
about astrology today
you just get a bad smell from it it just
feels like they're making it up
um but nonetheless i think that it
probably at some point
you know had a lot of pattern and story
in it that was
probably useful in helping to see how
the world kind of functions
um and obviously ancient astrology was
nothing like this kind of stupid
prediction type uh astrology it was more
this
this this vis this you know this canopy
of possibility
of like principalities that are up there
and there's an infinite amount of them
and so the question is like what
patterns will manifest themselves to you
right
so it's like why did they so people say
it's arbitrary but it's not arbitrary if
you make a pattern with like
stars it's going to end up end up being
something which is part of your
consciousness so there's definitely
going to be a connection between
the patterns which reveal themselves to
you from heaven
and your structures like the structures
of what
what of meaning so anyway so i i can
perceive that it's probably something
that had some
power before but today i it's just all
it's just all nonsense in my opinion
all right so charles harrow asks
i've been reading her brother's book
i've been trying to analyze the world
symbolically
i was hoping to get your comment on my
thinking if it's correct in regards to
inflation
so inflation would be symbolically
linked to time and the circle because it
erases people's savings which represents
their save's hard work
thus it acts as a force of
disintegration because it threatens to
make space
of work productivity pointless and when
inflation grows out of control it will
devour itself and lead to a new monetary
system
as people abandon the old one that is no
longer functional
which is akin to the snake that eats
itself
chris hear your thoughts on my phrasing
and any commentary that would have had
on the inflation given the period of
loose
financial policy yes i i agree with you
i think that
it it's not inflation uh
like just normal inflation like normal
inflation
in the terms of like let's say a normal
not a general inflation but like the
normal inflation of things like
the change of the price of things would
just be related to
to offer and demand and just that kind
of basic idea but
the way that inflation works today it it
has to do with
with credit it has to do with interest
and so
there's definitely something about
interest which is
part of the cyclical thing because it
you i've talked about i have a few
videos about interest by the way if
you're interested
but it's hard to think about it but the
thing about interest is that
you're borrowing from the future right
and so that's what part of the
acceleration
so it's it's it's like it's like you're
going into the future
you're grabbing possibility and you're
pulling it into now
and so you keep accelerating the wheel
because
you have to keep taking more from the
future in order for the system to work
so you're constantly
going into the future and pulling it
towards you so that then you have to do
that
do that again and so that is what brings
about
the the inevitable inflation and so
so i think that your analysis is is
correct but it has to do
the the way to understand it i think at
least is through
credit and interest um
so glory to so michael micah mueller
asked glory to god what is the symbolism
of a star hatchery
or nebula i have no idea
i don't know because i've never seen one
like i i don't see those things
they're not part of of experience they
they're very far away
um and so i don't i i i don't uh
i never thought about it to be honest
maybe i should i mean obviously it's now
part of reality so there's
there's something about it which that
should reveal some pattern
but at least until now it's it's just
always
some seemed like it was very far um
so
so g garcia says i had i had a question
about de hida's
thoughts on virology is there a way to
flip its virus
approach where christianity would infect
or lack of a better wor
for lack of a better word the world like
a double subversion
again for lack of a better word um
i think there's something like that
which is going to happen
i wouldn't use i wouldn't use it that
way
i think that what we're seeing
is
what we're seeing is that in the
postmodern
gesture of this undermining
uh so the always used to say that you
need to
you can't just destroy you have to
rebuild right he would say we
deconstruct so that we can
add value again back into the system but
that obviously
didn't happen and because that's not how
things work
but i think that what we're noticing is
that
it's more it's maybe the way to
understand it is that as
the as the virus kind of takes over
it's a it's it's weird because it's not
exactly that but it's something like
the virus has to make sure that the host
stays alive
or else the virus is gonna die so
that's probably the best way to
understand it is that
there's a there's a there's like a weird
thing where
it's like for the virus to remain active
it has to because it doesn't have
anything to there's nothing to replace
christianity with and so for the virus
to continue to act
they it has to keep its host alive and
that's what's happening
is that in the re-enactment of this
deconstruction
they constantly have to restate
the first position so they constantly
have to create
a world and then
deconstruct it and so that's why like i
mentioned that in my video on parasitic
storytelling
i think it has more to do with that i
don't think that
i don't think that christianity is going
to infect
the world um
and you can see and that's just not and
it's funny because that's not how
actually
at least maybe some people have done it
that way but at least traditional
christianity the way that it converts
people is a really different way it's
like
you you the way that christianity
converts people
to convert to converted ancient
empires is that there would be some
christians there let's say
in rome or you know in another country
and those christians would actually be
like model citizens there would be model
citizens which obey
all the rules all the the way
you know they were the they were model
romans they were model citizens
the only thing they did obey was this
prescription to not worship
you know to to to uh let's say to
sacrifice to the idols
so that's the first thing then the
second thing is they continue to submit
to the authority
the pagan authority until
that authority converts and so the
the transformation ends up happening
through the conversion of the king
that's constantine
uh which is in clovis and then uh
vladimir kiev uh none there's nonstop
like the king of armenia i forget his
name sorry
you know the the the same thing with the
king of ethiopia
so all of these these transformations
happen
through a so it's not at all an
infection
it's like it's it's actually it's it's
it's the christians reinforce the good
aspects of the culture
without trying to to uh to politically
destroy the the culture itself and then
the king converts so it's so i think
that
that's what christianity does
anyways
all right so i need to speed up a little
bit or else i'll never finish this so
so anders of stad asks
you have previously talked about flips
that occur between layers of
manifestation
and also about the flip which occurred
politically between the conservative and
liberal
in regards to the protection from the
virus first the conservative wanted to
isolate said borders
the liberals keep society open but then
after the flip conservative
wanted to reopen the due to economy and
liberals closed down
due to the potential of hurting those at
high risk
i've heard you say flips occur between
different layers of reality was this a
flip from attacking
virus to defending ourselves
where is christ in this flip yeah i
don't necessarily think christ is in
this flip
it's just the way reality works it's
just a strange thing that happens
uh and it sometimes it's not completely
it's not completely clear like one of
the things that
that paul vander clay talked about was
it had to do with strength and
compassion
and so it's like the way to show
strength and compassion
at some point flipped and and so
the main value ended up going to the
opposite in terms of effect
um and so that's something that that
happens you know in terms of the left
and the right
influence we i've talked about this
before where
it's like
let's say the tendency to move away from
the
the center depending on
the situ the context it can have
opposite appearances
so if you push someone away from the
center
right that is appears as harshness right
and so it's like
harshness is moving away from from the
center so it's like a
rigor right and that and so it's like
the left hand in the sense of
the goats move away from from christ but
from the point of view of the goats
or from the point of view of you when
you're moving away that it's actually
a form of breakdown a form of like
giving in to all the the outer things so
it's a form of fragmentation
when it's seen from the point of view of
the other side so that's
one of those that's the kind of flip
that happens um
sorry i'd have to analyze this one flip
more because it was obviously
it was so obvious when it happened it
was insane it was like from one day to
the next
you know it just just turned um so it'd
be interesting to understand if
it has something to do with that with
this idea of
with a way to view oneself and to view
the others and how it can
turn in there all right so anjo terpstra
asks is christ the symbol of all symbols
a hermited key which connects everything
together yes the beginning of the end
above and below
and it is therefore possible to read
christ back into the prototypes of the
old testament
or would this be a superficial vision of
christ no i think that that's it that's
the key the
story of christ is is the
you know the the keystone right if you
think of it in terms of an arc when he
says
the stone that was rejected by the
builders became the top of the arch
so it's like you know this whole edifice
and then you don't see christ you know
the image of christ is
is looks odd it's not it's not it
doesn't look like it's part of the
system
then when it's revealed then it becomes
the thing that holds the whole edifice
together
um and so in his life christ was not
they didn't see
what he was doing the patterns but now
as when it was
finished we look at it and we say wow
this is the story of everything like
this this story contains it all um and
so i think so i think it is definitely
i think not only you don't read christ
just back into
the prototypes of the old testament but
back into the myth in the myth
different myths and different fairy
tales and you know and then also
you back in the sense of out into all
the stories all the
all the even modern uh even modern
storytelling so
all right
all right so all right so mirko
quotes hannah arendt and so it's a long
quote but
man you guys you have to write shorter
questions but i will read
the quote from hannah arendt and we'll
see
so he quotes her from the origins of
totalitarianism
just as terror even in its pre-total
nearly tyrannical form ruins all
relationships between men
so the self-compulsion of ideological
thinking ruins all relationships with
reality
the preparation has succeeded when
people have lost contact with their
fellow men as well as the reality around
them
for together with these context men lose
the capacity of both
experience and thought the ideal subject
of totalitarian rule is not
the convinced nazi or the convinced
communists but people for whom the
distinction between fact and fiction
i.e the reality of experience and the
distinction between true and false i.e
the standards of thought no longer exist
yeah yeah yeah
and uh you know and one of the ways to
do that
and we saw this in 1984 you know
orwell described it very well is
is to change the the the facts
on a dime right so get people to believe
two opposite things
you know from one moment to the next and
and change the way they think and so
and so an example that's been happening
obviously is the masks it's like
don't wear masks they're stupid they're
silly they're useless
you know all these studies say masks are
useless and then from
one day to the next everybody has to
wear masks
follow the science you know from one day
to the next it was nuts
uh but then not just that like
like uh you know there's going to be
interference in the election
uh the russians are going to hack the
the the
voting machines you got to watch out
election happens
the other person wins it's impossible
that there's any corruption in the
election like
she can get people to believe things
completely opposite from each other
within days like that's that's like
you've got people then like it means
that all they do is
is they don't think anymore they just
base they just listen to what you tell
them and then they do it
um and so yeah
so i says do you think this is what's
happening in the world right now yes
contra racial cons [ __ ]
conspiratory the conspiratorial paranoia
is on
the rise in the world and most visibly
in the u.s seems
to me that mostly comes from the right
probably has a natural response to it so
it doesn't it doesn't just come from the
right
it's just that the conspiratorial
thinking on the left
is completely in the in the mainstream
media
like do you think being told that your
president is a manchurian candidate for
two years it's like three years or
something being told that
that your actual president is a spy from
another country
like if you don't think that that's
conspiratorial insanity
and that there are like these massive
networks of like white supremacists in
the us that are all organizing and that
are all
ready to like take over that's
conspiratorial thinking and so
it's like yeah the right has their
insane conspiracy theories like q
is just completely insane but it's not
just on one side so
um i think that
it's it has to do with this breakdown
like it has to do with the
the breakdown in meaning and so
yeah people are looking for authorities
to tell them what's real and they'll
just believe it
and so you know trust the plan is no
different than
you know follow the science it's like
okay dude you know who are these people
that are
i mean i i believe we need to to to
of course we you know as a christian i
believe we need to to to obey our
authorities but we
have to keep thinking we can't stop
thinking
yeah how did this fear into politics i
don't like that at least not too much
all right so christopher mihaly says
with the rising divisions in culture and
politics
in the us and abroad what do you believe
will finally be our
giant one-eyed psychic squid monster to
bring us together
will we have to wait for eschaton or any
semblance of unity
i hope we have to wait for the esk i
mean not i can't say that but
for sure the giant when it for those who
don't know what that's referring to
it's it's in the story of the watchmen
at the end of the story of watchmen uh
you discover a spoiler alert you
discover that one of the main characters
created a fake alien invasion
and that alien invasion is what united
the world together and stopped
the division and so you know
there's been an attempt to create this
giant one this
i mean covet is that it was that people
thought it was going to do that or they
hoped he was going to do that
they tried the environment for a while
hoping that they was going to do that
the world is in danger environment
global warming
everybody needs to unite and then now
kovid kovid kobid we need to unite it's
not working
um and so you know hey
an alien would do it right like the
story and watchman is
is uh is fine you know like it worked
so why wouldn't it work again
you know it's like it really feels like
we're being prepared for them to
announce to us that they're
aliens like they keep hinting at it
these weird ways
you know like they're gonna tell us all
the ufos so they're gonna reveal it so
it's like man
yeah and then we can you know we can
give uh
alan moore a nobel nobel prize or
something
for his watchmen story all right so
jason lindsay
asks hey jonathan i hope all is well for
you this year so far
it's not too much ask could you maybe
give a short summary of what the first
ten numbers represent in symbolism man
all the first ten i don't think i can
get to ten
so or point to place to find this
information
i've looked into numerology and gematria
but i fear
that i've only found the new aging
fragmented information on the subject
that might lead to distracting
rabbit holes or egyptology level
necromancy yeah that's not going to help
you
that for sure is not going to help you
um
so i don't know maybe i should i should
probably make a video about this like
the one is one is simple it's one it's
unity it's it's
the it's the oneness you know it's the
place where everything comes together
it's the origin
and the the place where things come
together so imagine if it was in pyramid
you'd have the one at the top
and you know and it's
it's
it's the so depending on how you count
it you can see one as the
unifying principle but you can also see
one as the first
those two are different in terms of
their use in mathematics but
nonetheless they they have a similar
function
in terms of what they're doing in terms
of origin and in terms of
of the absence of multiplicity right
okay
um and so two is duality right that's
not that hard to understand so you have
one then two is is a duality
and then three is unity and duality at
the same time
so it's you can understand three as a
triangle
and so it's like duality held by unity
right so that's probably the best way to
understand three
and so it's it's like it's a triangle
what unite
like i said so it's it's the duality but
with unity
okay and then four is
this it's usually an image of stability
so it's a square
think of it maybe if you think of it in
terms of geometry it's probably the
easiest way
for some of these to to understand so
so it's it it has to do with uh has to
do with
stability but it also has to do with the
limit
of conceptualization of quantity it's
like it
represents quantity in itself because
you really can't hold more than four
in your mind you know usually you have
to separate it
when you get to five you kind of have to
separate it between three and two it's
hard to hold more than four
in your mind um and so
let me stop there for the numbers but we
could go we could go into more
like we could go probably go up to ten
um at some point so hopefully that's at
least enough to
give you a hint so arie fisher says hi
jonathan what is your interpretation of
christ warning not to be lukewarm
most people seem to see it as an
admonition against being a fence sitter
and the assertion that it's better to do
something fully rather than
worry about its morality too much i'm
wondering about a more ontological
meaning
but also what do you think it means for
action
does it have to do with manifesting one
of the opposites cold or hot so that you
can
productively unite with the other what
is the difference between
being cold or being hot so
i think i think you're right no i think
you're right in the sense that
the idea of being neither cold nor hot
has to do with not the middle in the
sense of the unity
of of the two but the middle in the
sense of like the blah
like the the the non you like the
mixture or the the lack of
of solidity and so you're right that it
can have to do with a fence sitter in
the sense
that if action is required and you're
you're unable to act because you're you
don't want to take a position
then that that is probably what it's
talking about
um so
and so another thing too is that there
is a there is an
aspect of transcending opposites which
has to do with
going into the opposite so it's
so the idea for example that this is
actually it's interesting because it's
the difference between
the kind of modern the the recent or the
the more
contemporary um can i say this gender
theory
about how lack of
clear division between gender
is is equivalent to
the transcendence or the kind of or the
kind of union of the two and two to
something higher
and and it's the opposite right and so
the confusion of gender
doesn't it doesn't help you transcend
gender
what helps you transcend gender is to
embody
the the aspect that you are so it's like
to be a man and to do it in a way that
is holy
and full and and is
is uh let's say fulfilling the nature of
what that
is will make it possible for you to also
integrate your opposite and
that will happen in a way that so it's
like
and so so the idea of examine orthodoxy
you have this sense that
yes in for example in christ we
transcend the differences
like you're not a greek nor jew nor a
man or a woman all of this happens
as you enter into christ but at the
lower levels you do that
by virtuously embodying the identity
that has been given to you it's always
like yes you are
greek you know in at a lower level and
you live that
in a way that is that is virtuous and
and true and that through that then you
will be able to then
transcend that you know and see the the
other as
also being an image of god you know
rather than just being in this kind of
universalist vagueness that that doesn't
you know that doesn't
that leads to just a kind of weird
agnostic non-identity you know
um
right so eamon asks what happens to when
the chases sexual adventure how does the
meaning of a possible relationship
between him
and a woman get twisted by his chase
of many women oh so someone who
who wants to have a lot of relationships
well
i mean it's very simple like the more
relationships you have the harder it'll
be to join with one person
just because you you you should leave
something with that person
and you you connect with someone i mean
sexuality is a form of union and so if
you join yourself
with someone then you
[Music]
you will be joined with that person and
that it will
create in you a part of you that is
given to that person and that part you
won't be able to give it to
uh to your spouse because you can't
it's already been given to someone else
and so
that will fragment you and
it's a fragmentation that is very very
difficult to heal because
it's there right you can forgive you can
go beyond it but it's still there right
and so it has its fruits and it has its
effects so
be careful with that
todurate says why are there no real
romantic loves in the bible what are you
talking about
i don't think that's true many of my
friends are trying to
really hard to find something in the
bible to guide them in finding the right
one and so on
but they seem to always end up in the
book
of tobit the book of ruth and that's it
i guess the song of songs could also be
kind of fit in but i don't think there's
anything like romeo and juliet well i
hope there's nothing like romeo and
juliet because roman you and juliet kill
themselves
like you don't that's not that's a this
that's a
it's not a that's not a normal
relationship like it there's something
extremely uh twisted about romeo and
juliet and they
lead following their passions into into
death
you know it's it looks all good and nice
in
in the play but that's not that's
definitely not the the true union of
masculine and feminine the way it's
supposed to happen
so for sure the song of songs is
definitely a song
about desire and about um
about you know this kind of call back
and forth
call between the masculine and feminine
you know in the book of ruth you do get
a
very much a kind of romantic story um
where of a unexpected union let's say
you know and you also
see that with um in the story of isaac
and his his spouse there is you can feel
like there's
there's a there's some connection there
where he sees her
at the well
i forget i forget if it's isaac or jacob
oh man that's horrible this is
unforgivable
one of them is the servant that goes to
get i think it's isaac um
and then he sees her and he cries you
know and he kind of takes from his arms
there's some there's some images in
scripture but they're very
they're very um obviously just like all
everything in scripture is always
written in a very short
way so the wake will ask what do you
think of rastafarianism
um i don't know enough about
rastafarianism
it it doesn't seem to be
very building like it doesn't seem to
have
at least i don't know but at least what
my perception of it
is that it doesn't seem to have much
in terms of how something that can
create a
communion of saints let's say a
communion between people
i mean i know the weird the interesting
story that bob marley
uh converted to orthodoxy or to
ethiopian orthodoxy at the end of his
life and so i think that maybe the best
version of rastafarianism
is something which would lead you back
to uh
to uh ethiopian orthodoxy if that's
possible
so constanza trugillo asks or trujillo
do you see the inevitability of god's
will in tom holland's book
i know it might not mean much for many
but that book was what changed me from
an atheism
from atheism literally at the end of
2020.
i mean i really think that what i enjoy
about tom
holland's book is this is dominion
is that you feel in his writing that
he's
that he is kind of surprised at what he
himself is discovering
and so there's as if like he's seeing
how christianity is so inevitable and
how it just
permeates everything that you can almost
feel this like
weird giddy excitement of like telling
people about it and being like no you
know this thing you hate about the world
well
this is how you know without you know
the ethics behind it even if you think
you're being against christianity you're
actually
reaffirming christianity um and
and also like his his really really wise
perception about how
um
is the the piercing the illusion of the
enlightenment
right and how you know hidden in all the
the the pomp of the enlightenment and
its pretension
at having a kind of secular morality
that hidden underneath there was you
know
was the really dark stuff right and so
it's like
the the finality of humanism
is fifty shades of grey like that's the
finality of humanism
and it's like it was there right there
at the beginning it's like
it led to marquis like it led to to
uh weird will to power and fetishization
and uh and uh kind of breakdown you know
um and you see that happen in in in a
lot of
things it's like even in renaissance art
i talked about this with john
father john strickland again where you
see in the early renaissance this desire
to represent
form and balance and uh proportion and
then
right away very quickly there's a fall
into idiosyncrasy
and a desire to show weird stuff and and
kind of disturbing stuff
and uh to elongate the figures to to to
show people in very weird positions see
that in el greco
for example there's like a very kind of
disturbing sexuality about his
supposedly christian images
in greco especially um but you see an
art archimbaldo like you see
in um you know in uh
anyway so there are several several
places where you can see how
quickly the humanism degenerates
into a kind of uh fetishism right and so
it's like
people say oh the renaissance humanism
but but you know the renaissance also
gave us uh the machiavelli's prince
you know and so it's like these are the
undersides of the
of humanism that people don't like to
see
but that tom holland really saw it kind
of
perceived and and so so i do think that
he is kind of he is right now
tom holland is kind of manifesting this
like you said this will of god and he's
probably making christians
despite himself without even totally
being involved like or marginally being
involved in a church and
and and so yeah i really really enjoyed
it there are some things i disagree with
obviously and i mentioned them before
but
um so jezebel goes up against elijah and
jehu both
powerful archetypal men in different
ways why is it the
eunuchs who kill her um
i mean it probably mostly has to do with
this idea that
the the symbolism of the eunuch sorry to
tell you
the symbolism of a eunuch is like uh
it's something like uh
let's just say the eunuch is a marginal
figure right the eunuch
is a that's why the ethiopian eunuch is
like a double whammy
right it's like here's this person from
the edge of the world
who is also a eunuch and so it's like
neither male nor female
it's kind of like a you know indefinite
and so that's what eunuchs were and
that's what they were seen as
but that's also why they could act as
guards because they were indefinite
and they were not they had no stake
in identity because they couldn't
reproduce and they couldn't
they couldn't contin they were sterile
right and so this sterile uh ambiguous
figure
who act as guards you know and so
that's the nature of the margin folks
it's like
that it turns right so she she's k
she's she's also eaten by the dogs right
so it's like the dogs
this outer beast these marginal
guard figures you know and so it's like
it turns against you and that's that's
why
she's killed by the eunuchs
all right so christian soccer says love
seeing you and matt frat talk i spent my
government check
to be both your patrons well thank you
christian
uh that's kind of you in your discussion
about nakedness i got the sense
that if one got past the nakedness of
the
opposite sex and art that would become
blind to the virtues
the virtuous experience of nakedness and
marital unity yes
maybe it's similar to how priest hides
the host at the moment of consecration
yes the hiddenness preserves the
experience for the thing itself indeed
the old testament seeing god would kill
you some individuals
did see him in a mysterious way seeing
what's nakedness like exposing the image
of god and thus leading to a kind of
soul meaning
death yes there is a relationship like i
said between
the the nakedness or nudity and
sacredness
uh if it's proper and if it's improper
then it becomes a kind of
desacralization or a kind of
or like the nakedness of shame like i
said and so the idea of hiding something
precious
is to preserve its value like you said
and so
then the value of the unit of the union
of male and female
takes up all its power because it's kept
and it's
protected and it's and it's not thrown
out into the street and just
made accessible for anybody to look at
and to
to to think about so
all right so ricardo rojas asks
how should i approach my conversion to
orthodoxy i've been going to church a
couple times now and my spiritual father
is teaching me
the foundation of the faith should i
focus more on the theoretics reading
more
or in the practical aspect praying going
to liturgy to begin with thank you so
much
i would say listen to your spiritual
father that's what you should do
you should follow his lead and you
should you should ask him
what he thinks you need because he knows
you i don't know you so i don't know
what you need
but i would say the best is to ask him
so don palermo says
i am wrestling with identifying my given
unique inclinations and talents apart
from sinful tendencies of pride and
fragmentation
man sorry can you please shed some light
on
the commonality and difference at the
con confluence of idiosyncrasy and
multiplicity
with unity under christ wherein
distinction is preserved so i don't
totally yes there is definitely
a relationship between multiplicity and
idiosyncrasy
not necessarily but it's definitely
something which is connected together
you know because as you move towards
multiplicity
especially if you forget the unity
then that's when you encounter
idiosyncrasy
it's that's where in idiosyncrasy starts
to
take up room and starts to manifest
itself very strongly
and so you know that's why
the the demons that they represented
like medieval
paintings of hell are very idiosyncratic
they
they are they they've lost they don't
you don't have ways to connect them with
higher identities right they're just
these monsters really
so the monster is the ultimate
idiosyncrasy
and as you move towards multiplicity if
you forget unity that's what you get but
you
if you can move towards multiplicity and
remember unity
then you should be fine because that's
what pentecost is
pentecost is a movement to total
multiplicity
without forgetting unity
um all right so how many of these are
left there's quite a few here
man um
so amy asks in corinthians it says the
kingdom is not in word but in power
in same regard i've been thinking a lot
about how the question
the quest to become like christ is never
ending both
tell of a kind of living as or
embodiment of god rather than a
philosophical ideal of god
this kind of structure is it correct to
say that the bible acts as a kind of
mediator
between fugitive human and eternal
plight towards jesus like an anchor or
baseline or is it more
fitting and symbolic structure to be god
as the baseline and the bible as
fugitive with the human so i'm not
totally sure i understand what you mean
but maybe a way
to explain it is we need to understand
the scripture
as a as a solid
banister right or a solid
solid wall or a solid uh foundation
on which you can stand so it's actually
not above you it's something to
hold you in it's something to help you
not go astray and not lose yourself
right so it's
it kind of binds your attention um
and so and then the authority is god is
your is the authority of your spiritual
father your priest
your bishop you know your father or
mother
as a child the the authorities in
government all of these things above you
they're the ways in which you will then
embody your
actual life in in god whereas scripture
is more like
like the proper frame to to help you to
help you not lose
wonder in terms of your attention you
know so that's probably the best way to
understand it
um so jacobus
rodden is asks how do you interpret
matthew 10 34 39
not peace but sword guys you can't you
can't give me just
you guys can't give me just um one of
the reasons
one of the one of the things that
happened when i became orthodox is that
i somehow became very alienated to the
to like the verse
champion verse thing it's like i i know
scripture but i really don't
i almost don't want to remember the
chapter in verse i want a basic idea
where it is but i don't
i don't want to like say anyways um
so christ said do not think that i've
come to bring peace to the earth
i have not come to bring peace but a
sword i have come to set
man against his father and a daughter
against her mother and a daughter-in-law
against
and a person's enemies will be those of
his own household
whoever loves father mother more than me
is not worthy of me and whoever loves
son or daughter more than me is not
worthy of me
so this has to do with one aspect of
christ because
so christ i mean this is probably
something that i don't emphasize as
much as i should but the logos
both unifies and divides you know
the the logos is a sword the logos cuts
you know and it it uh it can also
yeah you know cut asunder things and so
especially if you are too attentive to
the things which are not the logos and
so
if you don't attend to the logos more
than you attend to the things
of the world then then the very logos
will fragment things will start
cutting them because you won't be able
to see
and to experience how all of these
things are joined together in one
in the logos if you're not attending to
the logos
and so you know if you just attend to
so think of it like
so think of it like if you if you're
doing something like if you if you if
you're doing
if you're doing something like a task i
don't know what like if you're doing a
task
and you're not attending to the purpose
of the task
well then what's going to happen is that
the elements of the task are gonna start
to fight amongst each other and they're
gonna start to fight against you because
you don't even know
what what's bringing you together
anymore right imagine if you
if you had a team and you forget what
the team is there for and
you don't have a proper hierarchy of
leadership and of
of attending to what it is you're trying
to accomplish then everybody's going to
start to argue
about what to do and how to do it and
and and all of this is going to be
to get to to increase if you
don't keep your eye on the goal and so
it's something like that that christ is
talking about
you know he's saying you need to
in in if you're
if anything below you is pulling you
away from
the from from god if anything below you
is pulling you away from
the logos then you need to to not attend
to it
you need to hate it you know but if you
attend to
god and if you attend then and if your
family attends to god especially
if you all come together and then it
it'll be the binding agent of your of
your society
but you know
i mean a good way to understand it it's
harder to understand if you think of
your family but if you understand it i
don't know like you
you used to be a druggie and you used to
hang out with with uh
with uh with a bunch of potheads and
then you're like
okay so now i want to follow jesus
and i want to stop taking drugs well
doing that
is going to create division in your
friendships it's going to break your
friendships it's going to destroy your
relationships
and you might think well that's horrible
but then that's because
the if you that those relationships were
not
properly ordered and were not ordered
for the right reasons so if you
if you don't have the proper
relationship even to your own family
then if you try to attend to something
higher
it's going to destroy your relationship
and
that's that's just how it is and i think
most people have actually experienced
that somehow
in at some level of reality so it's not
that mysterious
so jesse blaney fun question what has
been the most significant lesson
from all your years of marriage um
that i'm so selfish bastard like that's
you just being married and being like
deliberate about it makes you realize
just how selfish you are and just how
you know it's so difficult to
to kind of to give up
your protections your your
idiosyncrasies you know
your little desires in order to be in
communion with someone
and i think that that's what it's shown
me hopefully
hopefully it's not been it's not been a
complete obstacle to my
relationship i don't think so because we
we've been together for
you know 20 plus years so so
um yeah
so daniel demarco can you ask can you
please explain the meaning of the
symbols of the four evangelists how are
they related to the angels in ezekiel
and the beasts and revelations well they
are i talked about this a few times
before daniel
so um i can't obviously i can't expect
you to watch all my q a's
that's it's that's not the right way to
do this but um
they are related in the sense that
because
you can understand the four beasts in
ezekiel as kind of four
corners and so you can imagine there are
different ways to think about it but
there's a there's
in that story there's like a four right
so there's
there's like four wheels of the chariot
so there's this divine chariot which
kind of manifests itself
and this divine chariot is the support
for
the the support for the presence of god
so you can understand it as the four
corners of
the the the four corners of the uh the
ark of the covenant
this idea of the square which is the
container
of this divine revelation and so
that's the idea of the four beasts and
so obviously the each beast has a
certain meaning i won't go into that
too much but you can understand that
this four
you can understand it in space in terms
of the temple in terms of the ark of the
covenant
you know in terms of the throne with the
four feet in terms of the chariot with
four wheels
the stability of manifestation then you
can understand that the four
gospels do the same for christ
so it creates a stability in diversity
right so each corner is different each
gospel is different and by
being different it actually points to
the mystery
of christ which is above and which
unites all of these stories together
even despite their idiosyncrasies and so
it's a way
it's a way to to not
have this linear so christianity is
always this union and this balance
between unity and multiplicity
and so it's very different than the idea
of
let's say the quran which is comes down
like straight down from heaven and then
through muhammad
straight down and then it's like this is
it and so
and and here's this point whereas in
christianity
there's this idea that there's
let's say the one divides into four and
then creates a stable place
for the one to remain above and
mysterious and we can commune together
in that
unity the best way to understand it
um so charlie longoria says what does it
mean to sin against the holy spirit
it means that you don't accept
the spirit of god in in you don't accept
the transformation of your life
through the holy spirit that's what it
means and so
it is actually a direct causality
between not
being saved and not and sinning against
the holy spirit because
you're you're not being transformed if
you're not
if you don't let the spirit of god make
you into an image
into a resembling image of god then
that's it and that looks good it is yeah
so our generation is dumb says hello
good sir i hope you're doing well i'm
wondering how we can be praying for you
that's very kind of you
our generation is dumb i wish i had an
actual name
that i could say but that's okay i
understand uh
how can you pray for me i mean
i think i think that like there are
several things one of the things if you
want to pray for me
is is to help me not become
uh prideful because that's the difficult
like here i am i'm like
talking to you guys and you're listening
to me that's a very dangerous place to
be in terms of
my soul and so if you wanna if you wanna
don't pray that god humiliates me
at least don't don't pray that but maybe
at least i pray that god prevents me
from becoming prideful
it's much better um but i think that
that's that's something that i think
about and i worry about
and that's so so i think it's it's it's
good i think that
i need to to have discernment one of the
things that really makes me
suffer and that i don't know how to deal
with is like
as i is i don't know
so like even now like this thing like
this q a it's like okay so people send
me money and i answer these questions
the people who send me money and it's
and it's like
you know i get emails every day and i
get
these beautiful long descriptions of
people's stories and
they're asking me to interact with them
and i
and i don't know how to do it and so i
don't and
without it totally swamping me and
submerging me and so i've decided to not
answer emails anymore
but i i don't know i don't know if
that's so there's something about
discernment that i need to
to to um to figure out
to know you know how to discern where to
put my attention that's definitely
something so
thank you um
all right and so
so the blaze asked jonathan i've been
having a conversation with someone about
the nature of what is wrong with our
culture
i.e a lot um
he is of the belief that what is needed
most is a return to reason with the
capital r
yeah everything is seen instrumentally
discussing christianity only on the
ground of its utility
i very much understand your comments
regarding how hard it is to discuss the
meaning of crisis with someone
who has not had the intuition or had the
veil pulled back for them
regarding the questions of consciousness
while i understand that pure reading is
not sufficient
i have been having difficulty
articulating why
why is reason not enough and where did
the goddess of reason
in france go wrong any tips for helping
me put someone's finger
on the conceptual gap left in such a
world view
so it has to do with the problem of
one of them has to do with the problem
of infinite
with which is that the world is bigger
than what you can
gather into reason um
and ultimately god is
infinitely bigger than what you can
reason or
what you can grasp and so
reason only becomes very prideful right
it builds towers of babel
because it because it thinks that it
contains everything
but it doesn't and the remainder comes
back to bite it right
and so that's one of the problems with
reason
is that it doesn't look out for the
remainder
it doesn't rest on the sabbath you know
it doesn't
a lot of ways to to um to phrase it
right and so because of that
the the sabbath the remainder the
leftover the thing that doesn't fit
builds up
and uh and it collapses the system and
it's just
and it's just that's just how it works
you know and so you can't just have your
reason you need to leave
space for mystery above
and strangeness on the side like you
need both of those
without that then then you create uh
systems which become fragile and um
and they break apart so paul yuma
asks hi jonathan in the ring of quantity
and the signs of the times and symbols
of sacred science renegade lays out
some harsh criticism towards psychology
and more specifically towards
psychoanalysis
as a psychology student i recently
started an internship in retirement home
and i feel like most of the people
there need a priest more than a
psychologist in your view what is the
right place for psychology as a science
and as a clinical practice
i think it i don't think that it's
complete i think that there's room for
it i don't think it's completely
wrong i think that it has limits and
it's important to understand
those limits i think that understanding
the structure of the psyche
is helpful um
but i think that one of the problems
with psychology
and the reality of psychology is that
there's it doesn't take love into
account and so
a psychologist because a psychologist
cannot
love their client the way that
a father loves their son or the way that
a priest
loves his flock then
then they they've set out their own
limit
like they they just set out their own
limit so
that's what i think and so but i think
that someone
who is more like a father or a priest or
you know someone a pillar in a community
who understands the mechanisms of the
psyche
um it can be a tool it can be a tool to
help you
to not be stupid and then to not
act in ways that will be
counterproductive to you
but psychology has its limits because
it's it's the psyche looking at itself
and because
the psychologists and the psychiatrists
are have a pretension of science and of
standing
outside of of their own consciousness or
their own
system of consciousness then they they
have the same problem that
all these people have that brett
weinstein has it all i'm reading right
now
uh the master and his emissary by ian
mcgill chris and it is
unbearable to be honest i find it
unbearable
to read that book i'm getting very
frustrated reading it
and so i don't know if i'm gonna finish
like i'm in his second part where he
he basically thinks that he can
he can explain the whole history of the
west
based on right brain left brain
separation and it's like dude
seriously like it's just very
frustrating because he
he basically wrote a 600 page
elegy of intuition and
right brain dominance
he wrote this 600 page analysis
with footnotes and scholarly book about
the supremacy of of of intuition
and of uh of uh flux
right how the world is actually in uh
heraclic
uh eric heraclite was right and
heraclitus was right in terms of
of flux and of like context and this
kind of
you know and i'm like dude
like can you say performative
contradiction any louder
just very i don't know i'm just i just
find that stuff very frustrating
uh and i think i see that in
psychologists and and uh and
uh yeah i find that tough anyways
so sorry to ruin that book for you guys
if i know some people probably liked it
but i'm really struggling
to read it and to get something out of
it because i
see that blindness uh like my blind spot
and just glaring at me
all right so keenan wang says what's the
significance of christ's first miracle
being the turning of water into wine
it is the recreation of the world it's
it's
it's the beginning it's changing the
world
into and not just and it's more than
that it's actually more because
he could have turning water into
something like bread
would have been like creating the world
but turning water into wine is like not
just that it's like
turning the wood turning the water into
creation
and then bringing it into the
the edge like in the edge in the sense
of
of this ecstatic moment and the
and also this idea of death turned
against death
that's what wine is wine is fermentation
turned against itself
and so he's bringing it not only into
into the world into being but bringing
it to the end of his own story which
will be
this resurrection in the end and so it's
a it's a
yeah and he does it at a wedding and
it's like it's all there in terms of
this yeah it's a it's it's amazing
all right so ronaldo canada asked hey
jonathan i've heard some of the recent
videos you put out
or others that put out in conversation
with you and in one you spoke of
how we are called to die on purpose just
as christ did
i know you discussed this concept uh
some in the video
but i found it so fascinating that i was
hoping you could explain it a bit more
here
and so i mean it's not me it really is
you find that in the church fathers and
in the ascetic fathers especially
um i mean and it's the idea that christ
is one of the mysteries of christ which
is christ basically
changed the nature of death or showed us
what death is truly
for and and what it can do
and so this is of course in the actual
death
of that he that he went into
but it's also in terms of little moments
this little moment
of of will being willing to self
to sacrifice your immediate uh
kind of desire or your immediate pull is
means that you won't be a slave to it
you know and so you you sacrifice you
suck
so the idea is that and it's also this
idea that like instead of sacrificing
other things
because that's how sacrifice used to
work so it's like you take something
and then you sacrifice it and and then
that becomes
like a foundation for for a world but
the mystery that christ showed us is
that if you sacrifice yourself
then it becomes
like a seed that bears fruit into
eternity that bears fruit into
into way more fruit like just way more
than
than the idea of sacrificing you know
the the scapegoat or
or sacrificing some animal and so
and so you can kind of see it in your
life i hope that you can see
that when you if you sacrifice yourself
or your children then
they will become
like they will grow and they will become
more than what you were
and they'll become more in terms of
multi quantity
and they'll grow your fruits into the
world and so
and it's the same if you sacrifice
yourself for for others
uh then it will act as a kind of
seed that will and so that's the idea
that if you
if you don't if you don't sacrifice
yourself
then you then you will be a slave to the
things that kill you
because you it'll happen to you instead
of it
it'll be a passion that's what passion
means passion means something which is
done to you
right something that you incur and so
you could say that christ willfully went
into his passion
that is he he he
he was he willfully accepted that others
act upon him
and then that transformed reality
so yeah
well i'm done with the questions there
so let's go see
in the super chats if there are super
chats
alright so here we go
all right and so here we go so
sal d'or for five dollars says thank you
for your work brother i'm enjoying this
shirt and prince
well i don't know who you are salvador
because you have like an anime
thing but i'm happy that you that you
are enjoying the
the things that you that the prints for
i don't know if you if you mean
you got them through patreon but
probably not the shirts probably got
them on uh
on teespring and uh so thank you for
supporting what i'm doing i
i'm really enjoying the t-shirts thing i
didn't think i would enjoy it so much
i kind of like the idea because some
people are giving me pushback on it and
i understand but i kind of like the idea
that i'm making things that span
from the altar to the street like i like
that idea
you know the whole idea of hierarchy
where i can make a book cover or a
chalice or
or you know a processional cross but
then i'll also make
something that you know like a
20 year old guy in college you know will
want to wear
so i like that all right so
dirt poor robbins neil thank you for ten
dollars that's very kind of you
so martha emmer says can you comment on
the theotokos as both virgin and mother
in this she seems to inhabit the same
space as the bush
that burns and is not consumed yes and
the god who dies but then
lives but i can't work out the meeting
here so i don't know if it
has to do with the god that dies and
then lives but it definitely has to do
with
the bush that burns and is not consumed
and so you can understand that
the the ideas that the the extreme
of reality or like extreme potentiality
in order to house everything has to be
non-perturbed right
think of it almost like
think of it something like for the
the ocean to reflect the sun
it needs to not have waves on it and so
when it has waves on it it can reflect
the sun
in uh like a frac in a fragmented way
and so the light will sparkle but then
if you want to reflect the sun directly
then you have to you have to be still
there has to be this stillness
and so that's what the idea that
through her virginity the mary becomes
the mother of
the very principle of reality the very
the very thing that organizes reality um
and so you know you have to understand
your virginity obviously not just
in physic and physical terms
although that's part of it but you also
have to understand her virginity
in the yes like in this
giving up her will for the for the will
of god and so when
the archangel comes to to present to her
that she will be the one who will
receive the christ then this yes that
she answers
and then this this like
worship you know um it's kind of
making herself low saying yes
and then opening herself up in this like
in this worship and so
that is how being
of the relationship between being a
virgin and mother and so the
a normal mother is a is mitigated along
that line
right and so it's not the it's not the
the
so there but there's also an aspect of
that which is there even in like the
christian family for example and so
so the idea that so it's not it's not
virginity
total virginity because that's for the
totality but
in terms of properly hosting
the seed of her husband let's say
that a woman must be chased
to you know must be dedicated to her
husband and so
she's not a complete virgin for
everything but
she has to be virginal in relation to
all the other men
and chaste towards her husband because
if she's not then that will sow
confusion
obviously because you won't you might
not even know who the father is like
the this dedication and this this
capacity to be
a virgin to everything else is also what
is gives the possibility of
properly hosting the the the masculine
towards which it is
it is uh toward which she's dedicated
and so there's it's like a fractal it's
actually a
a mini version of this story of the
virgin mother
but it on a smaller scale right uh
but it can help you understand how
that's actually how like i said it's
actually how reality
how reality works you know you can't
have something be many things at the
same time it has to
it has to have a form of dedication
which appears as virginal to everything
else
right like it's not me it's not mixed
it's not confused with other things it's
this
space which is open only to one
to one manifestation and that's how you
have something
which can exist in the world without it
being confused
um anyways
i always feel like when i go too far in
these
these
descriptions then i then i'm losing
everybody and then like then they think
i'm just spotting gibberish
um all right so michael vitale is afford
uh
for us 20 thank you michael so shaky
raindrop for 10
how can i introduce the symbolic
worldview to my protestant biblical
literalist family
they reject extra biblical texts and
regard the church fathers as a cult
whoa a cult as in voodoo magics i would
call dude
occult the church fathers um
i mean you could be cheeky about it but
you know you wouldn't want to do that
you know
obviously the word trinity is not in the
bible
someone came up with that at some point
and that person would be called the
church father
you know um but you know that maybe
that'd be a that's a
more cheeky way the like the best way to
help
people see the symbolic world view is
through typology for people who love
scripture the best way to
to help them have a symbolic worldview
is to show them how the story of
when christ says you you you look
through the scripture
but you don't see that they talk about
me
it's like he's telling the pharisees
that but so many people are like that
and so it's like
if you can get them to understand that
all the scripture is talking about
christ
and then but not in a not in a vague way
not in like a kind of vague
yes you know the bible talks about
christ's way but rather that no
everything in scripture is referring to
christ like
every every every verse every sentence
in scripture
is pointing to the manifestation
of the divine logos in the world which
culminates
into the incarnation of the christ
of the god man and so and that can be
seen
in the typology between the story of
christ and genesis like you can find
you know help them see how for example
like
christ does certain things which don't
make sense
unless you see them as referring back
and answering the things that are
happening in the old testament
you can start by the things that christ
says so christ says you know as the
serpent was raised by moses so too the
son of man would be
was be lifted up and so it's like why is
he saying that it's not arbitrary
right he's he he he's he's making a
connection uh
can we expand that connection we talk
about it like
why is that connection made and so
working
on those types of moments where christ
himself
seems to seems to make connections and
saint paul for example makes connections
like
for example the book of hebrews is an
amazing book in terms to help people
see symbolism because
the author is basically telling you that
everything about
the old testament culminates into christ
and so
like what does that mean what is that
about what are the images so i think
that that's probably the best way to go
about that
and uh and then hopefully kind of build
on that and help them
see that
even help them see too that the reason
the reason why you
say for example that something like the
genesis story is a
is the pattern of reality or that
genesis story is
showing you how the world works is
because you love scripture
it's not it's not because you want to
debunk it because one of the problems is
that
a lot of protestants and i understand
this i sympathize
with this the the type of person they've
met in the past that have tried to
talk to them about symbolism have been
people who have wanted to do that
in order to discredit scripture so
they'll say
things like right they'll say things
like well the story of jesus you know
is just one other version of mithra or
one other version of this
other this other mythological figure
and so they see the analogy and so they
try to point to it in order to discredit
but it's like we're going at it from the
other way we're saying
no it's like this is
you know the the symbolism actually
gives
power to scripture it makes it a map of
reality it makes it something
by which you can live every breath of
your life
through right so it so it's it's it's
actually more
than the kind of moralizing and
technical
type of of uh of description you know
that that you'll find it
in certain branches of products is
protestantism so that's what i would
suggest but it's hard because it's also
emotional
and you can't get through emotional
emotions with arguments
um then it's and then
then then you just have to become a
saint you can't get around it
if you become a saint then then then
it'll be fine
um so bread pill says what is your
opinion on natural magic and
christianity
a la marcillo facino pico de la
mirandola
is it something you could do a video on
um
sure maybe sometime i don't like talking
about that stuff too much
but you know i'm not com
i don't i don't like people who
who have this strange on the one hand
you know
are traditional and like liturgy and and
like ritual and like
all that and then when they see any form
of
ritual action in in the world then
they're suspicious
of it it's like why are you suspicious
of the fact that
certain gestures would could create
certain results
and so i think in that sense i'm not
completely opposed
to some of the i some of the some of the
notions that you would find in something
like natural magic
of course the problem is
mostly related to to invocation
like people who who who do demonology
for example
like that stuff is extremely dangerous
like invoking
wild principalities you know in order to
gain power from them
is definitely something that will cause
problems so
i mean i would have to think about it
but maybe at some point i can make
videos about that so louis duran
asked how should i approach interpreting
the book of revelation that is not a
question you are allowed to ask louis
you're not allowed to ask that question
because it's the toughest thing to
interpret in the world and so it's like
uh you probably shouldn't and uh
you know it's just so difficult
so sorry sorry about that louis
so griswold grimm our friend griswold
says what's your view on hindu deities
and rituals to them at cern yeah i don't
know about that
people are talking about that weird i
don't know like
people conf are you talking about like
the weird tunnel thing
which got conflated with cern which is
actually not related to certain like the
weird tunnel
or or i know that in in at cern there's
a statue
of uh hindu deity i know that but i
didn't know that they actually had
rituals
um i know that some quantum
physicists and some like high physicists
have been influenced by
uh by vedanta in terms of
the these this you know the the
description of like principles of
manifestation some people
some of the physicists have been uh
influenced by buddhism and also vedanta
and just eastern thought in general um
and so i don't think much of it like i
i think i think people can't see
christianity
a lot of people for some reason they
can't see it properly maybe because it's
their own
thing so they feel like they have to
kind of look outside in order to see
something
but it's a it's a it's a dangerous game
because it um it undermines the world
so michael vitalis for 999 says can you
could you explain the symbolic meaning
of modern christian praise and worship
is the concert setting stage electric
guitar drums more shallow than the
liturgy what makes a good worship song
yes it is more shallow it's more shallow
first of all because of
even the spectacle aspect of it makes it
more shallow
the fact that it's set up like a show
the fact that that worship
bands are trying to imitate uh concerts
all of that is a problem it's a serious
problem it's it's it's a lack of
understanding of
what we're doing it's a lack of proper
vision of what
what's what it means to worship what it
means to be in communion what it means
to act
in a direction together all of these
things are
are just completely ignored or
and it has to do with it mostly has to
do with the problem of this
this kind of anti-symbolic vision where
people don't think that for example the
way that you do something
is related to the meaning you can't
separate the meaning with the way you do
something
the body and the soul and the spirit of
something are connected they're not
disconnected
so so so if you you know it's like you
worship has a content and it also has a
form which
it reflects its content and so if you
have a show you have people that are
dressed in ribbed jeans
with ripped clothing and and have funky
haircuts with
dye in their hair and and then they're
they're
singing uh songs which we're used to
hearing at concerts at rock concerts
then
yeah i mean it just doesn't uh
it just doesn't doesn't work um and so i
think it is more shallow and i have
nothing
against music and i even have nothing
against concerts and
there's room for dancing i believe all
these things like i just don't
i just think that it's a hierarchy until
you can't
have you can't have something which is
meant for the
tavern in the church because you're just
not understanding the proper
relationship of things
so so i think that a lot
but in the same at the same time like
let's be honest i prefer this
like i'd rather someone go to church on
a sunday
at a at a like a charismatic church with
a
really good band and a light show like
i'd prefer you go
there then go see i don't know some
death metal band or go see some really
horrendous rap artist that is disgusting
about his in his lyrics so it's like i
would it's still better
so you know hooray for praise songs i'm
totally fine with praise songs
um all right so velensky for five
dollars asked have you ever looked into
the rota square it is used in the movie
tenet
i would love to see your take on it um
yes i have thought about the rotas
square
okay i'm afraid that i probably couldn't
go into it right now
just because i would need to have it up
on the screen and kind of point out
to it it's a very fascinating square it
does seem to have
cosmic a cosmic meaning and it
it seems to have a cosmic meaning in
terms of
how the world turns or how the world
works um but um
but it's not super clear i mean maybe
i'll do a video on that
i'm afraid i it'd be hard for me to
answer
on the fly like that
um so the golden thread says thank you
for engaging with benjamin rva's
regularly long question it was a helpful
answer and not too technical greatly
appreciated well thank you golden thread
appreciate it um wow there's a lot uh
sufferbrand says
have you ever considered having nasim
talib on your show
he's mostly known for predicting the
2008 crash and his polemics against
academics
but has talked highly about religion and
his eastern ortho man i'm scared of
not seeing to live like he is a scary
dude
the things that he says on twitter like
terrify
is terrifying because he's also so smart
he's obviously an extremely intelligent
person and an extremely intelligent
mathematician who's definitely not
afraid of like flaunting his
intelligence and
using it to like crush his opponents and
so
it's like first of all i'm not sure he
would even agree to come on my show
but if he did it's like i'd be nervous
to talk about his concepts but
if it if there's an opportunity i'll do
it for sure
he's obviously an interesting fellow and
i think he is uh
orthodox i don't know how practicing he
is but he is orthodox
so david mac uh markham says happy feast
day for ten dollars thank you
david jacques christophe for five
dollars are you familiar with the show
neon genesis evangelii and yes
it's i know about it everybody's telling
me to read it to watch it but i haven't
watched it because i don't watch a lot
of
movies to be honest um
but i i'm actually trying to convince
like my daughter who's really into anime
she's 13 and she's like really into
anime almost too much but that's okay
uh i'm trying to convince her to watch
it with me but um
i haven't succeeded yet in convincing
her
[Music]
so travis jordan uh for us 42 thank you
travis wow that's amazing that's a
with no question so asana for 10 uh
written
british pounds do you think that the way
the world sees design today is how
people saw art in ancient times
um i would say uh similar
yes i would say similar but not exactly
the same in the sense that
design today has has a lot to do with
effect
like in terms of there's still a kind of
weird
not always but there's there's often an
alienation between
there's a type of design which is there
to just make the thing as functional as
possible
and then there's a type of design which
is there to just make
things pretty let's say but i think that
the best type of design would be
something which tries to make the thing
it's making
as functional as possible
in beauty at the same time because the
beauty ends up
actually being part of the function
ultimately
that's something that's hard for us to
understand but when you look at an
ancient sword you know or you look at
an ancient anything like these ancient
objects that were made
there's a there's a functionality but
there's also a
power of balance and and beauty and
ornament even
so so shaky rain dropped five dollars
that
asks thoughts on technology especially
in relation to techne and poesis how can
we rejoin art and utility
thank you um so yeah similar to the
other question
you know i think that
that's the problem like one of the big
problems of our world has been
the complete tearing asunder between
uh beauty and then
technique and poesis or
or or music musicality or pattern making
that that you would find in the ancient
world and so
you know i mean that's obviously one of
the reasons why i make
liturgical art is that i see in
liturgical art
a a place where it's still possible to
join all of those together
and to make objects which are both
technically proficient
are embodied principles and are also
you know uh reaching out in terms of
iconography and in terms of the the
possibility of creating
patterns of meaning at the same time so
yeah so tau for five
euros thank you love you man thank you
for everything you do god bless you
thank you tao that's very kind
uh eurodivi for five dollars hey
jonathan i love your work hopefully this
isn't too sensitive a topic but what are
your thoughts on origin
uh i mean look i think origin
is extremely important to christianity
and i think anybody who denies that
is deluding themselves origin you know
there's a reason why all the most
important fathers that's why
the reason why saint basil and saint
gregory you know the cappadocian fathers
published a a filocalia of origins work
they published
a kind of edited version of origins
works and so
we can't get rid of origin like
so and nonetheless it seems like
in his writings or maybe in his students
writings or those who
saw themselves as disciples of his
that some excesses were there and some
mistakes and some errors in terms of
of his his
tendency to be maybe a little too
speculative in terms of his
understanding
and so i have to recognize that as well
and recognize that because of that
the origin has been excluded from
the official you know the official
space but at the same time
he is very important and some of his
insights are
are very powerful and so just like
just for example so it's like just like
i am willing to read the iliad and see
insight in the iliad and just like i'm
willing to even look
at uh midrash like judaic midrash and
find some insight there
you know i have no problem with reading
origin and finding some insight in
origin as long as you are aware
of the dangers and aware of the of the
differences between
what has been accepted by the church and
some of the things that origen
has propounded or supposedly propounded
it's hard to know
because there's so much polemics in that
in that discussion but um
yeah that's what i think of origin
but having said that i haven't read as
much origin as
a lot of other people like i've read
some origin but not uh
i haven't like read everything he's
written um
oh so there's more questions all right
so so stuff
fried brains for ten dollars ask what is
the most righteous way to celebrate god
if we if i were
to peruse art i've been interested in
creating video games since i was young
can this be holy art without being tacky
uh i would say
probably no um
which i would say be careful don't try
to make
holy video games i would say try to make
good video games that are
that have
that are something like uh you know art
secular art that is kind of pointing in
the right direction you know because not
all art is
sacred in the in the strict sense not
all
art is made to to be part of a church
but it is possible to have a
a painting in the kings in the king's
dining hall that isn't a saints or that
isn't uh
that it's a historical beautiful
historical painting which
which emphasizes virtue and courage and
and those types of things so
i think that it's possible uh to make
video games like that um so i would say
that's probably the best thing to do i
don't know how you're gonna do it but
it's possible
so ron wood for ten dollars ask hey
jonathan perhaps this has been answered
but i'm curious
how the gods dog project is doing also
what do you think of paul's language of
creation videos and so
um so i send those to matsir i watch
i watch one or two and then i send them
to materia and so my tears pondering
uh you know paul's uh take on his
his book so that's that's interesting
i'm curious to met who's gonna have a
reaction or maybe
write a comment or something i hope
we'll see
uh in terms of god's dog it's
according to the plan it's this summer
like this summer
we're going to put out uh the
comic uh it's gonna be the first book
it's supposed to be like
four books or five books it depends if
we there's something we want to add
and there's also the um there's going to
be an extra book which is going to be
kind of like a more symbolic book
describing some of the symbolism of the
dog of the men and then also
mature city was going to write a book on
an article on samson
which is going to be awesome so we're
really excited we're
probably gonna do it as a crowdfunded
project and to be honest with you like
i'll be really honest with you
what i hope is gonna happen what i would
hope
would happen is that it it's very
successful and that
cord could quit his job and then make
the next book that i'll be honest with
you that's what i hope is going to
happen
now i don't know if that's possible um
because i really don't want to wait
another
like two three years to put out the
other book like i would i would really
like
to put out the the second book within a
year
of the first um but that would really
depend on whether we can make it
happen like all all out make it happen
so that everything's covered you know
the printing
the distribution and like basically
you know uh core salary um
and so that's tough man that's tough
like it's
it's a it's a it's it's a it's going to
end up being like a higher number but
you know so i'm hoping that's what's
going to happen if not then we'll put it
out and then you know then we'll
then people will wait until the next the
next book
which might will take a little longer so
so um
[Music]
max sheesh for five dollars that's what
you think about the lesser keys of
solomon and 72 sigils unicode emojis
i never thought i didn't i don't know
anything about this 1772 sigils unicode
emojis
so i wouldn't know how to answer the
relationship between those two
so brandon samuel 5 asked thoughts on
oswald spengler's
view of history rome babylon egypt being
typologically similar
decadent atheism i mean i think that
that's i haven't read spangler directly
i've read him through other sources but
i think that he has a i think that he
he has a good insight in what brings
about the end of civilization
and i think that his insight about how
this is something which seems to be
happening
now is particularly good so
you know um so stuff
stir for brains for 25 wow surfer brains
naseem is very gracious to people who
act through experience
he shows great grace to those who take
risks for what they believe god bless
you've helped me back into the path of
christ also bishop baron when
um so thanks so yeah maybe i could reach
out to to television he probably
won't answer because it's like he's a
pretty big fish
um but maybe i could try that'd be
interesting um and bishop baron
i don't know man you know you guys if
you want me to be on bishop baron you
guys need to make the pressure because
i've pretty much done everything i can
to
to get bishop baron to talk to me i've
talked to the right people
i've been able to email it seems the
right people
but no movement on that so if you want
if you want bishop baron you guys you
have to start
other people have to make noise so uh
so yeah so that's it all right so i
think we're done
i'm out of voice look at you guys you
guys are able to make me go
like a lot longer look it's 11 30. i
went from nine o'clock to 11 30.
so i have to say that i'm out of out of
voice
so so anyways guys thank you for for
uh for attend it for attending thank you
for for being there i really
appreciate it and uh there's some good
stuff
down the line you know and uh crazy
stuff everybody knows there's crazy
stuff coming
because i keep repeating it at non-stop
but oh yeah just to tell you that um
i need to i guess i need to mention this
that uh
this month's the january patreon video i
put out
on didn't put it out on youtube
i put it out on bit shoot because i'm
talking about
vaccines explicitly in the symbolism of
vaccines
and so i did not put it out here because
because it was maybe too much for the
algorithm
wouldn't like it so just just make sure
you know that
and uh and i probably will be making a
video
on the sidelines of that i might do a
video on the mark of the beast and talk
about that symbolism
and how it relates to the mark of kane
and then all the you know what a mark is
and all that stuff
so that might be interesting for people
to think about some of the craziness
that's going on right now
so everybody thank you
uh so nathan kurz last
last one last uh it says your twitter
exchange with jeff martell
got me to check out his podcast i'm very
excited about the prospect of youtube
talking we have talked
the the video is actually up on youtube
and i will make it public tomorrow so
you will enjoy that
it was an interesting conversation
because he he's like my weird
doppelganger and
and he he comes to very different
conclusions than i do
um so so i think you'll enjoy that
discussion all right guys
it was good to see everybody thanks
thanks for your time thanks to the
moderators
for those that that are still there and
i and i
yeah i really appreciate it so i'll see
you next month guys bye bye don't forget
sign up on the website
look at me i'm like i'm like like an
advertising guy alright bye-bye